i'm quick of the cave austin texas
america
hell yeah happy 911 let's watch some
dates i will never forget
hopefully we don't watch two people
crumble under the pressure
jet fuel
uh but we're gonna have a great night
tonight you know it is 9 11 so i brought
a very special guest uh who packs a
punch an explosive
punch
of
plane destroying
uh dynamite
okay uh hey that guy looks like a
terrorist
but yeah we got a great guest tonight uh
you might have seen her on kill tony a
woman who has personally met joe rogan a
comedian who is uh very very funny
please go up for holly johnson
ollie johnson in the building
two pounds not much holly
i like your 911 intro that was really
uplifting
nothing says dating like national
tragedy that's
hell yeah this gives me the butterflies
yep next week uh
we're gonna commemorate the columbine
shooting
but uh yeah well thank you guys for
coming uh welcome to our electric
chemistry holly and i have uh we're
really gonna
keep you awake for most of the show
uh any dating uh stories in your in your
life right now dating stories uh let's
see i started i started hitting the apps
again so uh that's new
um i went on a date today i cut it very
short
um i just you know just wasn't feeling
it
just like the united 93 flight you cut
it short in the field in pennsylvania
yeah
i was ready i was ready to jump out
that's what
all right well get your box
21 years ago
hey we even got a whole lady that signed
up in here wow look at all the men look
at all the men that signs
look at all these thirsty thirsty men
they're gonna end up [ __ ] each other
uh but if you're a woman please sign up
uh we need you oh [ __ ]
and uh
we're gonna have a fun time watching
people date each other we got
mia coming up
mia the only woman that signed up it is
you
please women sign up
and adam are a man
going on a date in front of his
peer group
adam r
lucky man going on a date with the only
woman mia
for one minute talk to each other like
you're on a date
hi
hi i'm adam
mia hey nice to meet you nice to meet
you too
how's it going
good
cool
so
i'm really happy we finally got to meet
because i've been waiting the media for
so long finally yeah
yeah
you're not happy about it
what do you mean i'm just joking it's
i'm just meeting you now and i'm excited
about that oh thank you me too yeah i
don't know if you can tell i can't tell
no what's something that you're into
when you have some free time do you have
any hobbies that i might be
yeah we could do together
is there multiple choices no you it's
it's a open-ended oh my god i hate those
questions
what are you doing do on your free time
but
i'm sorry
what do i like to do on my [ __ ]
um we'll
go to stand-ups
yeah end time
the electricity in the room oh my god
they had a great date i think adam are
already came in his pants
[Music]
he's been smiling this whole time he's
been up here what a joyful joyful man
this guy looks like if you just morphed
every single hinge profile together
uh mia so what did you think about adam
r's uh questions you seemed a little
lackluster on the last one
what
hey which one
uh the one about uh hobbies you're like
oh i hate free time questions and you
morphed this question into one that you
hated because i feel like you should you
shouldn't you wouldn't ask anyone of
your friend what do you like to do in
your free time you don't you don't say
that [ __ ] in real life yeah but so why
would you say that on the first day like
hey mia what's the favorite thing you've
ever been asked on a date
[Music]
favorite thing
[Music]
i think i just complaining a lot you
know that's just me she's asian so her
favorite question is does your mother
approve of me yet
oh
yeah that's why i'm here though like
yeah
i'm from taiwan
oh yeah my mom's never been here to the
united states she has but
she hasn't maybe adamara could marry her
and she got a green card what what adam
no i know what's my favorite question
what's your favorite question wait i can
marry you it's like your mom
dude would you want to marry it no i'm
excited green card
yeah what about green card what's your
favorite question
um
i don't have a favorite question well
you just said you did anyways
i'm really high i'm so sorry what kind
of time
she's really high yeah
which is illegal in taiwan
and
yeah that's why we're here but i mean
welcome to america thank you we got a
real slice of americana for you
this guy can give you a white picket
fence he looks like he looks like he's
from denmark
i have that you're right yeah
yeah what's the best uh
use that you had for your white
privilege anything cool that you did
with your white privilege
wow i've never been asked that so
directly
we've all been thinking it
i would say
you know
just not having to
explain when i'm in some kind of weird
situation like i remember one time i was
holding a bunch of women's purses like
outside of a basketball game
and no one even like you know had any
concerns about that they weren't like
what are you doing us of a basketball
game yeah
he's the whitest person here
that is very specific
yeah
it is were the women playing basketball
were they all in the bathroom how did
you get all these purses how did you
round up
seven women's purses
i mean the story is
not that awesome it was some friends i
went to like a high school basketball
game and then like one of the
yeah there was like
i had to take the purses to the car for
some reason i don't even it was a while
ago i just remember thinking like wow my
white privilege is showing now because
if i were not white then there'd be a
lot more questions about why i'm just
like walking around with all these
literally like purses
let's move on
a lot of a lot of teams have water boys
not a lot of teams have purse boys
um so
adam r anything you'd like to ask mia
about her background in taiwan
[Music]
sure yeah okay let's see i'll give us
some multiple choices this time did you
a enjoy living in taiwan
b
dislike living in taiwan
or
c
fill in yeah ali above
and why what
what did you think why
did you like it or not
in taiwan i like taiwan but it's just
like the air
quality is not good
because of the factory i don't know what
we're making though but just like
my town seriously it's true like every
night the air and the water's been
polluted too come to texas for the air
quality yeah
yeah got all the hay fever that you
could want
yeah cedar cedar fever uh adam are
presenting an asian with a multiple
choice question i don't know if that's
oh i like it
i guess
mia what do you think about uh dating a
white man
dating white men i don't
what is that is there multiple two like
aren't they yeah are they weird a white
man be a white man or see a white man
the asian tradition of dating a white
man
if you're a woman
do you uh do you like white men yeah
you're not supposed to you're not
supposed to take life
i mean we don't have enough women as it
is i'm not racist so
nice yeah well how about attacking a
racist but right
what do you find different about white
men and asian men
white men
there's a lot um
oh my god
i feel i'll get in trouble
don't worry xi jinping is not watching
yeah oh that's right
um
i don't know at first i thought
cause like back home they say they have
bigger dicks
but there's like they say that here too
no
yeah it's not true wow
i'm sorry
sorry white man but that's not a problem
right that's a dick of a taiwanese man
they i mean taiwanese men they're
usually not circumcised so hell yeah
i'm sorry
it's just the truth and then
i don't know i think it's the weather
because the weather is like pretty humid
there so the dick is like
always
it's always dangling yeah
that's why i'm not there anymore good to
know one of the reasons not all of them
come to taiwan your dick will grow
bigger yeah
adam r are you a grower or a shower
oh man
no
how many purses
if if you're talking about his linkedin
network definitely a grower for sure
how many purses can you hang off your
dick
that was a good i should have tried that
my white privilege would probably have
allowed it and that would have been fine
a lot more uh persons could be held by a
black person but
adam or uh what do you do for work what
tech company do you work for do you want
to you want to guess like just based on
my oracles and
not okay
i'm not a i'm not a tech guy indeed not
a tech not a tech guy
no
mia do you want to guess do you want to
guess what my job is that could be maybe
interesting do you want to guess what i
do why don't you just tell us
i'm a psychiatrist
oh [ __ ]
he's been judging us the whole time
so let's just say that you're a
psychiatrist and uh mia comes in and uh
she's got a lot of issues she lived in
taiwan yeah i do
let's uh let's see you unpack uh
taiwanese trauma and scene action
[Laughter]
hi so
what brings you in today
what kind of psychiatrist like taiwanese
i don't even have that there
it's
too advanced
i don't it's like i'm just venting right
now she's schizophrenic she's talking to
people that are not in the room
no i am
i'm just i'm just high as [ __ ]
i am seriously though like why am i the
only woman
what do you think holly is
oh you mean
[Applause]
is the session are you no no okay yeah i
think it's awesome that you were willing
to sign up for this
i have i have like eight friends in the
audience and none of them were willing
to do it so you're showing a lot of
bravery there you're
unseen stop pulling on the tablecloth
give it up for this couple it's a
therapy i was supposed to be comfortable
mia is trying to make that tablecloth
into a t-shirt because that's what they
do in taiwan yeah yeah uh mia so what do
you think about america
i mean i've been here since i was 16.
and
i happened to be a lot of places in the
united states hell yeah yeah my first
first time i went to i came to america i
went to hawaii
because my fam because my parents like
i don't know
your parents have money wanted to go to
the taiwan of america
yeah yeah yeah
no i always think go to an island
yeah another island of america because
we always feel that we're the 51st state
like [ __ ] what is that country
country whatever puerto rico whatever
it's not a country it's a yeah they're
trying to be the part of the united
states and taiwanese over there but like
[Music]
yeah you guys want to be puerto rico
yeah
yeah that's our goal right now try to be
you know the first not just me i think
because
and i'm like working on the visa thing
and it's annoying and then puerto rico
people will be like
well luckily we have adam r here who can
help you with your marital yeah i know
that's why i'm here you can get a card
as green as you can
see later yeah shut the [ __ ] up i'm
sorry
i'm so sorry anyways adam r would you
marry mia to get her a green card
i
you know mia seems awesome i think it's
a little too early to talk about
marriage we should probably do a date
like
maybe with like in a stadium with even
more people
that's this is like we'll work up to it
what do you think
[Music]
don't do this more yeah
no we're like
this will be for like three more hours
in front of everybody i'm seeing myself
right now i hope there's no camera right
her family has all committed suicide i
have bad news for you man this is being
live streamed um on a camera that mia's
family has actually made for us
um
so can i can i ask a question can i so
you think i look like the like the hinge
profile like the
the amalgamation do you have like am i
too basic as far as my my polo and my
dress do you have some data some tips as
far as my style i don't know i just feel
like i've seen you like eight times
that's that's all that's weird because
like i don't think we ever i don't think
we ever matched no we haven't
yeah she swiped less
eight times damn
i'm still in denial that i need to be on
meds so i probably just saw a
psychiatrist and just went right past it
i say that i'm a physician on there
because
you know
some people have negative judgments of
my field
what are some of the negative judgments
that people have yelled at you
um
yeah the
most i mean it's not that fun to talk
about but it's like at some of the
conferences there's like protests from
scientologists because they're like
we're controlling everyone's mind and
we're
just trying to like medicate all the
children and like
brainwash everyone which we're trying to
help people i may or may not have
stumbled into a museum that that was
right i've seen there
yeah it's like in hollywood i've seen
that it was the only thing that was free
that's really the only reason i went in
there
yeah
what would you say to a scientologist
that said that you're destroying minds
and stuff
um maybe i would ask i would ask an
open-ended question about why
how does that make you feel yeah yeah
because that always brings out a great
conversation like your hobbies mr
scientologist i mean i don't know if it
would really be that helpful for me to
argue with them just maybe try to relate
to them and see why they think that and
then give my perspective and
maybe
go from there you know
see if they want to go on a date with me
in front of an audience and then go from
there psychologically
insane
so mia what do you do for a living i'm a
student i go to ucla
oh hell yeah you're a little
far from your school right now yeah i'm
on summer break summer break oh [ __ ]
yeah the west coast starts later yeah
yeah so uh what are you studying
psychiatry no
no um
i study english literature
wow yeah
that's i don't even study that [ __ ]
i was born here
what what's your favorite uh english
literature
no i'm just trying to get a degree
[Music]
i was about to be like mia that's
awesome because i love reading too we
have something in common there but mia
you do know like communications exists
right yeah
that one's way easier
i know but
let me major in a language i don't
i don't uh well i'm just trying to
i'm just trying to learn i don't
learn english like right now i feel like
it's i'm practicing a lot
yeah this is practice it's free
it's nice i paid like 14 bucks to get in
here you got to come for free the guy
paid
my man
oh you're already on a date tonight yeah
that's why i'm just venting here maybe
that's why you're not
what you're so open to adam r
what uh what made you go on a date while
you're on a date
because he told me to sign up
oh oh you're you're you're you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're you're you're you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're you're yeah so you're already on
a date whoa i don't think that's a date
i think that's a
[Music]
i don't know what that pimp
are you being trapped
is there a sign in the bathroom that
kind of like there's a number you can
call if that's happening okay i will pay
attention to that
she's taiwanese she's soon gonna own all
of us
we all owe her money
or something
uh what did you think about nancy pelosi
that's kind of funny i don't know
okay
yeah don't talk bad about nancy pelosi
with her nephew right here
no no nothing wrong with her i don't i
don't like politics to be honest with
you what do you like what are your some
of your hobbies
yes
yes you got this mia you have time to
think about it you got it you got it
okay hiking
pedal boarding yeah paddle boarding go
to movie movie
holy [ __ ] is this what hinge is like
yeah yeah yeah
but then it's like when you ask what do
i like to do that's the only thing i can
think of do you like bird scooter rides
on the beach no no
no
it's too much what have you done in
austin that uh has been fun
coming here
okay besides that besides the thing that
we already know you did
um
like
on my way to austin i got arrested
hell yeah this is going to texas yeah
that's there's the first thing happened
what were you arrested for evading
arrest
which i wasn't
i was just nervous
because there's a lot just to drive i
don't blame him you're evading all these
questions yeah okay
thank you i feel validated why the cops
keep coming i'm just trying to get it
places you know
well luckily we're located right next to
a police station so oh [ __ ] them oh my
god
they're [ __ ] invading yeah and then
they put me in jail for night
and the [ __ ] gave me no blanket
it was so cold there did you make your
own though you you found a way yeah
there's one here there's nothing you
don't know this in the jail she's
traumatized yeah
kind of no no no it's okay
no you should come to other people we're
better than texas county jail
we're better than jail i don't
it's the ac's
it's all the same though yeah but at
least you have a blanket
so uh that's kind of a crash course in
american criminal justice system uh
adam what do you think about uh
getting vaccinated i think it's great
yeah i think we should all do it
really you're not a okay are you an
anti-vaxxer mia no i don't care it hurts
that's just what i don't like it hurts
yeah but it's it's you know protects you
protects other people mia giving trump
supporters new ammo
don't get vaccinated
it's an ouchie
i was curious if the date is more or
less fun than a night in jail so far
because the night is the day more or
less enjoyable than being incarcerated
because i'm not at our date right now oh
yeah he's about to kidnap you right
because i i'm i was just kind of curious
would you prefer to be on this date
right now in front of this crowd yeah
yeah okay yeah of course sam yeah yeah
yeah okay glad we established that this
is all consensual
nobody is yeah no force to do any of
this no way
uh
adam
you look like william defoe if he was
five foot taller ah we're not done yet
i've heard that before i've heard yeah
and it's fitting because you look like
the green goblin right now
yeah i do like it's green is my favorite
color and i like to think of a willem
dhoba maybe not quite as old you know
yeah you're a very young man how how old
are you i'm 39. holy [ __ ] you're old as
[ __ ]
i'm 23.
okay
the fbi has been called
holly what do you think about this uh
psychiatrist and this student
uh i i don't think it's a match
purposely i mean the candle's over here
which i think is a symbol of just no
thanks
the romance is gone i think she's having
more fun with that blanket than she is
with the
stage yeah only they had like a beer
right now it's so cool
she's getting ready to be a tiger mom
she's already hectoring adam no i'm my
and then that's why i'm like this right
now i'm sorry i don't mean to really a
tiger man what did your mom make you do
that was very tight yeah no [ __ ]
what she made you [ __ ] piano
that's why the piano is poor though i
don't do anything with the piano i just
[ __ ] there sometime
you feel rich though
doing that
[ __ ] on the piano that's like some
asian [ __ ]
[ __ ] on the piano
yeah says asian as [ __ ]
yeah adam are have you ever [ __ ] on a
jar of mayonnaise
you know i i haven't but i'm pretty
open-minded
what do you like to do for fun what are
your hobbies
i like to play tennis i like to read
books yeah i know very white hobby
yeah i play tennis what do you like to
read reading books i like how to play
tennis how to play tennis roger
federer's biography
yeah you know i also um
yeah i'm
also like traveling you know a lot of
kind of basic basic things
i want to do more social stuff actually
so i'm really excited that i'm trying to
that i'm out here i'm kind of i want to
maybe do some like acting or more on
stage stuff because i i kind of like
being in front of everyone so i might do
more of them okay
good yeah what a great answer awesome
you nailed it
so what do you think about psychiatry
are you gonna stay in it for a long time
are you gonna psychoanalyze
people and stuff i think
yeah i think so it's you know it's a lot
of training and i i think we do like
some positive
work at the end of the day so i'm
planning to stick with it what's the
craziest thing that's happened that you
can tell us
the craziest thing that i can tell you
about
i mean sometimes
a patient will try to seduce you that's
maybe like the yeah don't worry that's
not happening i know it's that's
yeah yeah actually i so i'm on the
dating apps too and then one time in a
different city
um
i saw one of my patients on the apps and
like i had the version where i could see
that she like swiped on me and
so then i had to talk i was in training
still so i had to talk to my supervisor
about it i was like kind of excited that
i got a match but then i was like oh but
this is this is a problem he's on the
healthcare dating professional app
called syringe
give it up for adam r and mia
let's see what she does with the
we're gonna call your mom if you don't
make it perfect
uh that's a threat in asian culture
that's our n-word
we got another couple cut whoa
professionally
done give it up for a charlie
t
am i picking is there a woman yeah
charlie t
all right and the lucky lady
it's gonna be marlene
marlene coming up
charlie t is not here sorry you lost
your chance
trace
we've gone with the no last name
thing to cut down on the
unwanted internet marlene is there
marlene she's coming right up she's i
think she's in the stairwell
okay she's buying drugs here she comes
oh all right
we got marlo charlie trace
going on a date with what is her name
marlene marlene
and starting now
hi
how about now sorry oh excuse me 30
seconds in
how you doing today great how about you
good i'm doing great great
have you ever been arrested
no no never
oh wow
not much excitement going on huh oh
once or twice or a few more times than
that maybe
yeah are you from texas or
i'm mexican you're mexican
chinese mexican oh sweet sweet
so you're on vacation or you live here
um i recently moved hey no videos
you might go to jail tonight
hopefully not i hope not too
it's cold out here
that's why you got that scene
oh wow
give it up for
charlie trace
and marlena
charlie with your signature giggle
yeah there we go always puts the ladies
at ease
giggling
maniacally
what uh what did you get arrested for
like
so
like
[Music]
there was a
burglary one time
that was that was embarrassing that was
so embarrassing the burglary can you
tell us what you took besides marlene's
heart
uh
so i had a co-defender with me there was
two of us i didn't take anything
i was there we went to we went there for
specifically to look for something we
didn't find that and this knucklehead
took some other [ __ ] and
we got caught
and we got caught like i said it was
embarrassing he knew the kid it was in
his neighborhood um and the neighbor
noticed us coming out of the house
recognized my friend called his mom
but what happened was i dropped my i
dropped my id in the house
yeah so i couldn't get away with it i
couldn't just have him take the whole
fall because they said you know who's
this charles with that was with you why
did you bring your id away that's what
i'm saying young and stupid and i
climbed through a window to do a
burglary with basketball shorts on and
my id and the basketball nothing holds
in basketball shorts you're supposed to
just play basketball and [ __ ]
yeah especially those taiwanese dicks
with all this swampy heat
that's a that's a hilarious story i'm
glad that you gave up your life of crime
and now what are you doing
i'm hanging out
yeah
yeah yeah i mean
marlene what do you think about criminal
this american criminal
well
have you stopped
yeah yeah
well actually [ __ ]
that was a specific question i do like
petty crimes too a little pet a little
petty crime [ __ ] okay
nobody gets hurt nobody gets hurt petty
crimes are fun sorry petty
i like the color red
what the [ __ ] dude
marlena what uh how long have you been
in texas
a couple of years how do you like it i
like it a lot people are really friendly
yeah
even criminals
we got the nicest criminals here
smooth michael jackson stop
well not that smooth
terrible
um but yeah so that's fun uh what do you
what do you uh think about dating in
texas
i think
i mean it's the same anywhere it's
a lot of swiping and not a lot of
response
that's too bad
like uh charles's crime career
a lot of a lot of
arrests no
nothing to show for it a lot of stuff a
lot of swiping dropping your name places
and hoping nobody finds it
so charles uh how do you like dating in
texas
well i'm new i'm new to texas i just
moved here recently so how do you like
it
i haven't dated until i i i never i
haven't i've just been hanging out never
really met a girl like
dating wise and i met one girl
and that's been phenomenal
awesome yeah how did you meet her
i actually met her here at the creek
on monday after kill tony this is his
hunting ground so
just a warning yeah uh
so uh what do you guys talk about
everything from a to z
give every single give us a what a d
a d
yeah the d mine yeah do you talk about
that d the d yeah absolutely
i'm sorry i don't want to be embarrassed
anyways uh marlena
where would you take charles on a date
to the police station
i mean we're here
yeah that's good enough one and done
i like your style
you're gonna kick him to the curb
uh charles where would you take marlena
on a date
vulcan first because then we'd come here
after i usually go there first the
vulcan gas company
okay another rival comedy club don't go
there come here
um that's fun uh yeah so on a monday is
the best night at that spot
that i didn't mean to mention yeah
that's true
marlena what uh have you ever been close
to getting arrested maybe you could
relate to charles a little
bit
no
she came here from mexico that's a risk
she she raised the
yeah i'm sure how did you come here from
mexico actually it's a lot more risk
over there thank you
yeah i had a lot of friends that you
know the mafia yeah she's mexican and
she's not even a criminal just shooting
everyone on the streets a few of my
friends got bullets just because of that
like got bullets
yeah they mean got shot by bullets yeah
they didn't like win bullets at the fair
birthday gift that's why i came here
so it's a lot safer
that's true
yeah we uh
we don't shoot as many people
in texas
i've seen somebody get shot right here
and why did you shoot him
i didn't i didn't it was a female that
got shot too
oh it was right here man
okay are we bonding over shooting excuse
me
this is bonding over shooting now
yeah you guys uh have a lot in common
why why did she get shot
so this it was late at night a couple
weeks ago right here about three o'clock
in the morning i heard an argument i
looked over seeing a group of people
i don't where i come from arguing you
don't think nothing of it so i'm
standing there i was smoking
and i heard the female voice you're
gonna have to shoot me
again i wouldn't think nothing of it i
come from you know environments that
aren't so friendly so i look over and
somebody walked away from the group and
just i see the arm go up and just shot
two times i seen her drop in the street
then turn around and run turn around and
shot three more times there's five shots
right there on
seventh street in natchez man ready uh
did he drop his id
i don't know i took off running actually
the opposite way he went running because
i well he dropped your id
you got arrested for it no she survived
i looked it up
why is this such a heavy episode
that's what i mean she survived i didn't
want it to be so bleak she lived lived
thank you for that happy ending
i was happy about that a bright ray of
sunshine
uh marlena what's the craziest thing
that you've seen
gun violence wise
well actually where i live is not the
safest place so i do see people with
machetes going by my front door where do
you live in austin where they have
people going by with machetes
east alter
eastworth
are you sure those aren't just lawn care
specialists
[Laughter]
i'm not gonna ask
well yeah i guess they all look the same
to me
um
marlena you said uh
you're mexican and i'm chinese
why what
why did you say that i'm not mexican
i'm not even chinese
well i'm glad that we're all minorities
with two white people on stage
i'm white i don't look like another guy
he can't be white i don't look like the
last guy you're you're puerto rican
right i am white i just don't look like
the last guy guess we'll never know
no offense the last guy was guys
the same
um yeah that's cool um
holly what do you think about this
couple you think they have a chance uh
well with the history of gunfire um
and the stories about finding bodies i
think i think it's been a really fuzzy
and romantic evening
what uh what's your favorite uh gun
violence that you saw
that i saw yeah
no actually don't i have lived without
seeing one myself so i'm happy about
that
i mean all right i've heard it but
charles is like
why
he has more stories for that
well charles uh
anything you'd like to say to marlena to
woo her and win her over
um
i i won't get arrested again like i said
it's just petty crimes
ticket stuff you know notice how you
didn't say i won't commit crimes again
yeah cause i like i said the petty stuff
like i like to smoke weed here in austin
because it's illegal like walk past the
cop with a joint leg
wow i have a little anxiety boy gives
myself some anxiety a little he doesn't
follow the laws of the land
uh
marlena anything that you'd like to say
to charles
maybe his miranda rights
i don't know
she doesn't know
um well i think you guys are a great
couple you know you guys can make it
work
if he wasn't already on a date
but uh yeah this is those you guys were
great you know you said like seven words
please appreciate you
you did all the talking
um
anything you'd like to say to us
questions comments
i appreciate you all having me here
about funny as hell
i thought you're gonna say something you
just said really quietly oh me yeah
you asked if he had questions
and then that was it
marlena would you like to give us
a woo to end the date
hell yeah that was telling about
trending
marlena and charles
we got a whole woman left we're gonna
have to use her sparingly
we got cody coming up
a male
1
[Music]
and one woman
all right last lady of the night
hannah r
hannah r
not to be confused with adam r
i hope they're not dating
i don't see them oh they're right there
hannah r and cody one minute starting
now
hello
turn the switch
am i on
all right hello hello so where were you
during 9 11. i was
in first grade oh i was also in first
grade hi i i honestly missed the
announcement the first couple of times
and wondered why everyone was panicking
at lunch and that was when it was
explained to me it's like i walked home
from school oh everyone else got picked
up oh i love coming from school with my
sister i wish you actually
i lived close enough i wish they'd let
me walk home but no they kept me 35
miles from the pentagon
wow
they lived much farther away from the
pentagon than that
[Music]
so have you ever been arrested i have
not no i've come close once but i've
never been arrested
have you ever been arrested
yeah but i was 17 so it doesn't count ah
there you go i was i was also a minor
when i was almost arrested what were you
almost arrested for oh i was arrested oh
okay
i was seventeen what were you arrested
for at 17. uh underage drinking oh okay
fun uh they thought i was going to blow
up my school
end time
for cody
a domestic terrorist
and hannah are
a person that parties and has fun and
lives life without hurting others
uh so what were where were you drinking
at hannah where that you got caught and
arrested
um i was
at a party in a neighborhood and tell
cody what a party is okay so parties
where cool people gather and hang out
sometimes
i guess i drank too much it was a vodka
slurpee and then i felt like i was gonna
have to throw up so the party got busted
but i was in the street vomiting so i
got arrested
when you're throwing up yeah it was sad
vodka slurpee damn you guys really are
in high school drinking at 17.
that's a horrible horrible combination
uh cody why did you blow up your school
i did not blow up my school why were you
thinking about it i wasn't even thinking
about it but rumors happened that whole
snowball effect and what was reported
and what i said wasn't the same but
that was enough for
whoever decided i had to go to a
disciplinary academy for
half a month
goddamn can we get adam r back this guy
is depressing as [ __ ]
wait a minute so what was it that you
were trying to say that somehow got
confused with i'm gonna blow up the
school i told someone that they were
going to get shot
oh it was just one kid so why is
everybody making a big fuss i i don't
know how it went from one person getting
shot to i was going to blow up the
entire school
it
you're not a monster it was it was
strange because like the police officer
came into like the
classroom and just asked me very
politely and i walked very nicely to the
office like okay so do you know why
we're here i had no idea and they had to
explain it to me and i was
very confused so this person that that
you wanted to shoot um what did they
want to shoot them
why did you was it a joke what was the
context
i think it was a racial joke of some
kind oh that's better i remember it was
it was something like that i was like
you can't make those jokes they're going
to get you shot was what i was i think
saying something like that oh okay yeah
we do normally tell this story on first
dates not on first dates but it does
come up from time to time
i mean it has to eventually right yeah i
mean he was almost arrested you were
actually arrested
yeah because you were under seven earned
under eighteen yeah record i was 16 god
that works like the officers are like no
we're not going to arrest you though
because he was looking at me and
realizing were you wearing this outfit
no
maybe i should have been i don't know if
it would have been a plus or a minus in
my case
[Music]
cody you said you didn't hear the
announcements for 9 11. no what kind of
announcements did they give for 9 11. uh
apparently our principal addressed the
entire school over intercom just to let
them know that there was a national
tragedy going on
and that we weren't going to have a
normal school day and i i was reading a
book apparently and then you were like
somebody's about to get shot
many years later but yeah
different school
that's cool i like how you guys found
out you guys are the same age based on
how old you were when 9 11 happened
that's cool
so you could walk to the pentagon
no i could just walk home from school oh
but you're close to the pentagon yes
yeah yeah so is it true was there a
plane that actually hit the pentagon or
was it a
missile something like that i don't know
my mom's friend worked there at the time
so she was freaking out i guess too
distracted to pick me up from school
yeah
911 does that to you
stressful times yeah
anyways um
yeah you uh
you're the same age luckily you know you
all experienced 9 11 together
what uh what how would you say that
changed you as a person cody
uh
i don't know if it changed me but it
definitely changed the world that i
thought i was gonna get at like five six
years old into what it is now what world
did you think you were gonna get at five
or six years old something with a little
bit more
tolerance
and for friendly i mean
i grew up watching magic school bus and
captain planet so i was thinking it was
gonna be
a happier
world i guess than it turned out to be
yeah the 90s were just like the magic
school bus
a lot of flying vehicles uh hannah what
uh how long have you been in austin
since february
wow recent move
what do you do in austin
i walk on the trail
i go out to the bars do you get paid for
walking on trails oh you mean like work
right yeah um well i work remote so
i don't really work in austin
like i do work here physically but yeah
what is what is it that you do to make
money and survive i work for a tech
startup i do ux ui
yeah you do what
web design web design ux
user experience i'm asians
yep
that's fun i work in adjacent fields
cool yes
two techies meeting up
getting all techy with each other
where would you like to go coding with
cody
[Laughter]
cody explodey
i don't know i'm a little scared there
might be a threat on wherever
we go to work
red river just like the blood when
cody's done with his work if you're if
your waitress is bad somebody's gonna
get shot
no one liked that
no they didn't like it
i could have told you that
[Music]
cody so um what's your favorite uh
way to get arrested
have you ever been close to getting
arrested before yes
when they thought i was gonna no besides
that besides that no you've been
following the law yes it was a very
scary
i don't know
four hours of
police questioning
okay i just don't believe that you
follow the law with that bandana
oh i mean i avoid the law i don't say i
or i avoid the law enforcement we should
say okay that's smart
um
hannah would you like to do drugs with
cody
sure
this is why you got arrested for
underage drinking
cody you have a very strong resemblance
to shaggy from scooby-doo do you ever
get that get that sometimes yeah
what what are your what are your
equivalent of scooby snacks
edibles
i mean yeah
yeah
edibles that's fun hannah are you still
doing drugs a lot are you uh
have you abandoned your 17 year old ways
i mean i smoke weed dabble in some other
things but call in the police
we're gonna give her an interesting
story for dates yeah it's just petty
crime though so it's
oh we gotta get the last guy echo
petty crime is fine petty crime is okay
you make petty crime look a lot more fun
than the last guy did
that last guy was scary
drugs are more fun than robbery
just my opinion
cody if he's a bumper sticker
he has a lot of them on his car
he definitely has coexist that's just
cody if you uh had to commit a crime
which crime would it be
uh
[Music]
what crime are you this is a buzzfeed
article
i guess public intoxication
okay
so you're going to say public urination
the only thing cody's going to be
blowing up is rachel's phone
is her name rachel [ __ ]
[Laughter]
sorry hans that's okay
so hannah what uh
what do you think about uh cody's uh
have you ever dated a stoner before
yeah they just don't look like stoners
they look like adam r
no i hate false advertising what can i
say yeah have you ever dated a guy
that's going to convince you that living
outdoors is healthier
uh yeah
all right well here he is again
off the grid or something
did you uh have a little gabby patito
situation did you ever go camping with
uh with a man enough with the tragedy my
god
i did want to do van life my mom was
like you can't do it alone and i was
like i guess i have to get a boyfriend
yeah i was like well if you get a
boyfriend you're going to get murdered
so
now i can't do that cody what kind of
car do you drive
drive a honda element
i don't know what that looks like is
that the boxy one okay toaster it could
be a van if you have
a short bedroom it's like a little bomb
[Music]
so did you ever uh end up dating anyone
that was like sort of like you know
would might make terroristic threats or
i i went out on a date with a guy who
said that he
was arrested for
um
threatening to shoot up at school just
now yeah cody like well no he had a bb
gun and he was shooting
cans and then
it was facing in elementary school and
then
all the moms came to the house and the
police came and he hid inside and then
he told me that he was afraid so
inside made it worse and then he had a
felony
and then he had to move
that's a great first date this guy
really is opening up strong i've heard
this before that's probably why i didn't
get arrested because i didn't act guilty
i just went oh sure what do you want me
for yeah what are we talking about
what's going on he just said zoinks when
the police showed up
cody who's uh who's some of the people
that you've dated what are they like
um the people that i've dated usually
people that i've known for several
months years ahead of time and i've kind
of learned that it's called stalking
please stop doing that
the friends beforehand and i
i don't think i like doing that anymore
because now i know too much about all my
friends and hanging out is awkward
now you want complete strangers i just
want to start with someone new
hannah what kind of uh do you have a
type
would your friend say you have a type i
used to
what was it
like
brown hair beard
oh no
but like not that kind of beer whoa
not that kind of beard
damn
[Laughter]
anyway i can shave
or not
that's cool
it's like a facial hair thing with you
you got like a hair brown hair thing i
guess yeah i don't like guys that look
like myself like i don't like blondes or
people yeah you're not a lesbian
yeah maybe that's it
a very heterosexual woman looking for a
brown-haired man
uh cody what do you think about uh
you know
uh the brown hair thing like i think
you're you're in there i yeah i think
god is what you have to describe the
facial hair more because i can change
it's easy
grows every day it's really annoying to
keep up with yeah
that's the kind of guys you have a type
i'm trying to branch out of it so okay
that's fair
he's like did somebody say branch
that was funny to me
why because he looks like a squirrel he
just looks like he'd really be into
nature i don't know
i don't know what it was
what's your favorite kind of granola bar
um
whichever one has the most fruits in it
[Music]
i don't know
so you uh you're in tech you worked uh
you work at a tech company what uh what
was school like for you college were you
uh going to a pretty prestigious school
no i went to a small school um back home
and then easier to bomb that way
what's that
i said it's easier to bomb if it's a
smaller school yeah it was a party
school
hell yeah so you didn't uh stop drinking
after you got caught at 17.
what
what what did you study in school uh
graphic design
nice
yeah
i didn't get a degree i got hired and
they kept telling me no you don't need
to go get your degree yeah okay just
don't fire me now
okay cody you're the only one laughing
at your jokes
nervous
cody what makes you the most nervous on
a date
uh
[Music]
i don't know lots of things general
um
making a fool of myself which is why you
do it on stage so you can just
laugh about it
have you had a date on stage before yes
there's a probably more on this stage
than the other stage or any other day
it's really
yeah he's the majority of your dates are
right here
it's about 50 50 really but yeah sure
majority
okay
um cody is actually a loyal customer so
let's be a little little gentle with him
right now
[Laughter]
hannah where do most of your dates come
from
um i was on hinge for a while is that
what you mean yeah sure yeah you're
hinging and then um then i decided to
meet people in person and those people
were way weirder than the people in him
[Music]
yeah
yep that's where they they're all at all
the weirdest guys are in the weir the
real life they're in the real world
so uh
what do you what would what do you think
uh cody's hinge profile would say under
the buy under the picture
in a hammock in the trees i definitely
have the orange leaf emoji for sure yeah
damn it what does that mean
[Music]
it's amazing that one's weed
i feel like there's a picture of you and
a tree somewhere
yeah hinge there's lots of pictures of
me on the tree
yeah you're a tree hugger
sure yeah um cody what do you think
hannah's hinge profile would say
i don't know but i get the feeling that
the pictures would all be like
business smart
to the side of oh no
totally wrong
like just got cancelled not quite a suit
jacket but just dressed i don't know
what i think of as just just more
official than business casual
i'll show you it after okay
cody just landed a
date on linkedin
[Laughter]
uh give it up for cody and hannah they
went on a date together
they're gonna
talk to each other afterwards
hopefully from a respectful distance
um we got a
segment on this show that we like to
call find our producer sam kuiper
a date
uh
and it's happening right the [ __ ] now
give it up for sam kuiper producer
of other people comedy
here he comes
sam kuiper from alabama standing five
foot
six
it gets shorter every time
we've got blonde wavy hair and a strong
chiseled
chest
uh any ladies if you would like to date
sam kuiper now is your chance
any uh the longer it takes the more
he gets emotional
oh there's a name in here okay
sam
we don't need you get off the stage oh
perfect thank you no i'm just kidding so
you're gonna go on a date with a
straight woman her name is jaz marie
jazz marie
come on down
[Music]
if it was too late to sign up
[Music]
he knows the ins and outs how are you
see a professional at work
jazz i like your kicks
are they real
are they real
you hesitated
please put the switch on the microphone
on
sorry
yeah sorry um you were telling me your
shoes are real yeah they're from the
nike store they look exclusive which is
what i like about them but they're not
so you're like you like are you a
sneaker head then i wish but i'm poor so
i'm not but i if i could i would
do you have a fake a favorite shoe
no i feel like i just like shoes that
have a lot of like color that are fun
i'm just really tired of like the basic
like
nike white air forces or just
like the black and white vans which
don't get wrong i own a pair but i feel
like i want i want to see people branch
out with their shoes more
where were you on 911
[Music]
um i was one year old oh [ __ ] so i have
no recollection of 9 11 whatsoever
uh all i know is my parents story of it
and time give it up for my uh
not merlin jazz marie
another mexican woman
and sam kuiper yeah alex shoes producer
wow what a great
great time that we learned uh jasmine is
poor
uh
she spent all her money on her shoes
um
and sam
is
he really didn't learn that much about
you no
mysterious what do you want to know talk
about talk to me
okay so alabama what was that like are
you a country boy uh yeah my parents
divorced when i was four so like my dad
lived in the country and my mom we lived
kind of by the beach so i had best of
both worlds i guess a divorce dad and a
beach yeah
oh it's a lot of times two christmases a
lot of
other things you know
uh yeah but it's i left when i was ten i
moved to indiana and then um
california and now texas but
you saved yourself with california and
texas for a second i thought you only
had the boring states but yeah that was
that got better alabama's pretty cool
they like to
[ __ ] their sisters like i guess uh
hell yeah
better than cody's date yeah
sam i think you should go back to saying
i like shoes i think i think that was
better conversation
i uh i don't have a sister so don't
worry about it
not comforting but okay
because if he did have a sister exactly
i'd [ __ ] the [ __ ] over here wait a
minute i don't know
you wouldn't be here right now yeah
jazz maria
you have a very beautiful t-shirt on uh
whitney houston
i mean you were born
in 2000 what the [ __ ] do you know about
whitney houston that was even before 9
11. i it's not like i'm like a mega fan
or anything i just
like the colors i'm going to make my
sound sound even more poor it was a
cheap shirt at t.j.maxx so i got it
because it was cute and it was yellow
hell yeah ironic yeah
did you sing it all can you sing
not publicly okay in the shower one of
those private singers
you know how much money they make
[Laughter]
um
sam would you like to give us a little
tune
maybe about jazz marie and her shoes
you wanna
there we go
getting serenaded
this is all right forest sound i don't
know what this is i can't
[Music]
whitney houston
oh whitney houston
how i miss you whitney houston
what the [ __ ] is this i think about all
the time
whitney
houston
and you run through my mind
brittany
houston
what is your name
jasmine jasmirie all right
no it's okay because i lowkey forgot
your name also okay
i'm going to put it
yeah
that was like uh when william shatner
sang rocket man
which is a reference you won't
understand jazz marina get it
uh
what what was that dude are you is this
why white people don't rap i went with
the flow you know
[Music]
i felt like i was under water
i i felt it was very i had to like i
didn't have the pipes to like sing
something so i just slammed poetry kind
of
felt right
slam
do you uh listen to a lot of white
people music jasmine that's actually so
funny no
that is hilarious
i say it's hilarious because i
never get references people make and so
for like a really long time before i
ever i've never listened to nickelback's
music but i swore it was a rapper like i
saw i swore he was a rapper just sounded
like a rapper named me and it wasn't
until college that i had to be informed
by other white people who he was
only white people
i just white people be snitching
yeah
how long did you know how long did you
think nickelback was a rap group well i
just as soon as i heard it i was like oh
i just made an assumption so i was 12 19
when i found out the truth 19. so 19
years so that was your 9 11.
that was my 9 that was my white cultural
awakening for sure i realized i didn't
know anything yeah welcome to white
people nickelback is our god yeah i'm
white in this example
i i dated a guy who loved nickelback
and i put a little note in my phone that
said if this doesn't work out just
remember he's a nickelback fan
that's good all right did you have like
the nickelback
ringtone life hacks with holly jones
have a nickelback ringtone
it's not that big of a fan
i like how you say you don't understand
references that people make and you're
wearing a whitney houston t-shirt okay
but i admitted in the beginning i got it
because it was a cheap key i like your
style you keep knocking like help it
don't matter you don't want to be rich
but those hoop earrings and that kind of
shirt i thought it was like a memorial
for a friend that died
you know what they say about hoop
earrings what do they say about hooping
i'm asking do you know
well okay yesterday when i was out i
this guy came up to me he's like you
latina and i was like yeah and he's like
yeah i could tell from the hoop earrings
and he just walked away he literally was
like yeah i could tell and just walked
away and so that's the only yeah not a
lot of indians wearing hoop earrings
the bigger the oh the
bigger the hoe you heard that
i haven't yeah
that's a thing i didn't make it up you
guys are all
hyper dating
into white culture again another slam
poem
slam poet tree
wow and uh what
yeah well look be concerned about
yourself dude you're [ __ ] this up
uh
oh [ __ ] some woman thinks she can do
better yeah you want to go on a lesbian
date with jazz marie come on
let's reward hecklers that's kind of
what we do i was kind of just
making her think about things but i
guess this is fine too
here she comes a loud annoying person
going on a date with a beautiful and
kind
jazz marie
hello what's your name hi
alex how are you okay nice to meet you
nice to meet you nice to meet you as
well you seem very excited to be up here
i am
okay good
[Laughter]
i mean i think that lost comment is a
little bit [ __ ] to be honest
hoops are great man you should rock them
no yeah this is like my go-to it's a
classic look it's part of the culture
you know
yeah exactly you know we wear hoops
producer dude wherever you are
by the camera where are you from i'm
from austin austin like your whole life
just born and raised here yeah i'm a
local why would you like do you ever
plan on leaving
if my family wasn't here [ __ ] yeah man
how tired all these people moving here
like i'd be in colorado or portland
why colorado portland besides the wheat
it's peaceful it's great scenery
yeah
they have legalized weed
yes
i feel like anyone who says they want to
move to colorado i instantly think
they're a pothead and most of the time
i'm right and it's fine and time give it
up for jazz marie and what was your name
alex are you a stoner because it doesn't
sound like it
no i used to be now i work in tech
hell yeah
you're just tired of dealing with all
these nerds you got to yell out
[ __ ]
yeah man
so you're tired of people moving here so
you want to go to colorado or portland
because it's peaceful
have you heard what's happening in
portland it's like kind of not that
peaceful
no i don't watch the neons
well maybe you should research a little
before
you move somewhere
or yell out during the show
she just calls me and informs me what's
going on
that's cool
jasmine what do you think about uh this
date
i kind of wish she said something
sexual
or inappropriate i mean
i don't know i mean you choose your
words um i think you know i'm learning a
lot
i'm surprised that you wanted to go to
colorado portland it's not the
i was surprised that you're like born
and raised in austin i just like i'm
just always really surprised when people
stay in their same city their whole
lives i don't get that that's very
confusing to me
yeah what a weirdo why did you do that
i mean again family
if they weren't here like i'd be gone
but to switch topics
gorgeous thank you thank you many do
have you ever been in a
bisexual relationship jesmarie um no i
have not
okay you're just wearing a whitney
houston t-shirt
yeah uh what was your name again
me ashley whatever
alex alex have you ever dated a woman
i may have messed around with girls but
i never actually seriously dated one
yeah you went to college
yeah a party
you probably got arrested for underage
drinking
actually no it was fortunate
to me
of all the people i think you would get
arrested for underage drinking
and not
hannah but uh alex uh what do you think
about uh going on your first uh you know
date with a woman do you think that
maybe it's something that you'll do more
because you seem to like yell out a lot
like amanda's
i mean i think i could do a better job
yeah
of yelling out
well it seems like you're kind of like
low energy at least you know like maybe
you could like
engage and say something inappropriate
just to get the juices flowing
be creative
if you had to say something
inappropriate to jazz marie right now
what would it be and what was the last
time you had sex
oh
i'm honestly not a very sexual person so
i haven't really had like sex in like a
year but i just i'm not like i never
really go on dates
at all so the hoop thing was like the
complete opposite yeah yeah that's why i
was very surprised that that's the
impression i give because that's not
jess is not who i am
yeah i saw that sam she's got the
tiniest vagina ever
uh alex uh what do you think about uh
jazz marie she's not you know she hasn't
had sex in a while apparently
by choice
i mean it doesn't really matter like if
you're super sexual and not sexual like
you are you are are you sexual or are
you just smiling like that all the time
no i'm pretty [ __ ] sexual i'm pretty
much horny every day
and how do you usually hear you might
want to get the psychiatrist in on that
that doesn't sound
healthy
the psychiatrist is taking notes right
now he has a prescription for you after
the show
do you are you in a relationship now
me
oh my god
i think i'm getting laid after the show
are you uh currently seeing someone or
multiple people
no comment
wow she's a player what what exactly
what concoction of drugs are you on
right now that's what i want to do
literally about four tequilas
four tequilas
it seems like you're way louder down
there than you are up here
probably yeah
so if you had to say anything to men
right now just as a group
like just yell at them just get all your
anger out
just tell them what you really
feel say
say what's honest
i don't know there's so many things sam
is right there
just yell at sam right now is that the
producer that's the producer
um i don't know you probably shouldn't
judge women by their earrings
let that be a lesson to you saying
she really
she really roasted you there
with that life lesson
like i saw you and i was going to the
bathroom and i was like oh man that
dude's kind of cute yeah i might like
talk to him later and then i saw you up
here
and i was like no boo i have a feeling
you might be thinking the same exact
thing you know what
likely yeah
i had that moment when he said the
sister thing that was that was my oh god
no [ __ ] no moment i think the entire
audience felt bad
[ __ ] you sam um
[Laughter]
alex so what do you what do you think
about uh
sam uh you know maybe
editing you out of the show like maybe
you should be a little nicer to him
oh my god
what is is this like opiates or
no it's 14 no
tequilas usually people get more drunk
you just get more sedated
are you
are you mexican
i'm half and huh
half what
i don't know guatemalan
can i ask what you think i am earlier
you said i was mexican okay but i'm not
mexican oh really no colombian no
i'm gonna get it wrong
[Music]
what do you think
i love having people guess my ethnicity
i think it's so fun because i've gotten
a lot of different answers
puerto rican i am puerto rican
wow give it up for a resident racist
holly johnston
[Laughter]
what's the most puerto rican thing that
you've done so far
puerto rican thing i've done i don't
know i go there like i used to go there
like almost every summer i'm in love
with that bunny i would do anything for
that man it's probably one of the most
modern puerto rican things about me
oh most
one of the most puerto rican things
about me too is i'm
pro-independence of the island but
that's not a very common opinion on the
island so maybe not very puerto rican
but i was looking for more like you like
to stab your food or
stop my food what do you mean stop my
food like oh yeah
yeah
hi yeah that's where you're thinking
[Laughter]
whatever
get up for jazz marie and alex they went
on a date together
that was the show what do you think
holly do you think any of these dates
have a chance uh i think i think cody
and hannah i think
oh i think maybe hannah's even though
it's not the facial hair she likes and
she was very clear to point that out not
like that
uh very very harsh uh you know
way to make another insole
uh this one had a lot of tragedy on it i
was not expecting so many uh so many
violent tragedies
on this dating show
it was more of a drama than a comedy
show
but you can check out holly
she is online and doing shows all over
the world yeah online that's that's
enough information i think for them to
find me hollyjohnson.com
that's not okay
i don't own that domain i didn't i
didn't get it check out there's a t in
there somewhere so that's for you to
figure holly johnston
uh my name is hans kim that's the show
thank you guys so much good night